what's going on reject nation Greg al
Bakir Cisco Ramon from the flash over
here or Tony yelling me either relying
hard let's go no just go alone it's in
the gamer on twitchy live events
throughout throughout the week I
occasionally do guest on his little
twitch channel he's got going on
so disclaimer I have gamer guests cuz
I'm not a legit gamer I'm more like when
I'm with my gamer friends I love playing
the video game but my actual friends who
play games consistently they all have
very busy schedules this week you might
know them you know Andrew Breanna white
dan Elissa they're a lot very busy
schedules they'll be on throughout the
week but if I don't get a trailer up at
your convenient time it is done it is
because I am working around their
schedule so there you must you might be
patient for some trailers but Tony
he plays battlefront so I have Tony here
for battlefront to the official gameplay
ensure a look this is something that
when it comes out he'll for sure be
streaming it for sure and I would love
to play it I played some of that upfront
one force awakens
[Music]
and your personal thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Wow we're gonna play that part back
[Music]
we go down there's right run
[Music]
[Music]
you're an exercise
[Music]
that right there interpreter that was
actually Andy first dear that was I was
amazing that was an amazing trailer just
like the all-around battle it just looks
so bad at the jet pack it looks like
they're bringing back classes which is
just like exactly what this game needed
because then you get to try different
units and in the squad you'll have to
get stuck with the same kind of
characters you get to like switch it out
all around man that looks beautiful
that's beautiful
it reminds me of like the actual
battlefield games with just like a
little about for battlefield 4 and 5
like I'm not as much 5 as for but it
just was like all-out war and you really
felt like you were in the war in like
the multiplayer game but this one it
just feels like ok let's it's the exact
same thing but we're just gonna add all
Star Wars and yeah even look like parts
of like the buildings were getting
destroyed yeah I was like a big feature
in battlefield that's like always
interesting to see when you first go
into the map it looks beautiful and then
by the end of the match everything is
all destroyed it'll be really dope to
actually see like wherever planet you're
fighting on like actual destruction
because you guys went into war I think
battlefront is more exciting than ever
especially because they've read launch
Star Wars The Force awakens in row 1 and
they have it the next episode coming out
of the last Jedi coming out later on
this year I think Star Wars has ever
been more exciting so they're giving you
the most immersive experience into two
star wars part of it yeah as much as
possible because that's what you really
that's the part the game is taking the
most advantage of while they while it
expands on storyline in certain aspects
and wily and while this one will feature
an actual story yeah the main part of it
is like I think I saw the gameplay
trailers getting people so jacked up
where's that Darth Maul part before we
continue oh my god that dark mole part
was so good and it was just based on
like that felt like you're actually
running through the levels in the last
game when you're playing at the
superhero characters you just felt like
you were just lunging at yeah absolutely
you didn't really
like you were the actual character it
looks like they're putting actual moves
into like the hero yeah Darth Maul's one
of the few good things to come out of
episode one and he's a character that
we've always kind of wanted to return on
overturning the Clone Wars and stuff and
that moment donees throwing his
lightsaber it looks if you play a slow
it down a little bit it looks like when
it's coming back that it strikes one of
the one of the troopers is it one of the
features that if you throw it even on
its weight returning back to you that it
can still strike down people as well
because that would be a really cool
feature to have it's the first trailer
that we want teasing dark Maul
I just feel like they're going to put a
lot of power into using that character
cuz feel like when you watch episode one
like oh man you kind of don't want dark
Malta's I look like such a badass
character and you only got to see so
much of them but in these games getting
into the story mode which is super
important for Star Wars like you know a
story will like what's the point of even
using Star Wars as the name you've got
to get in depth when you can make a game
like this because video games you just
put little extra things the see Darth
Maul man it's going to be great to play
as him was insanely appealing about the
game is that there's multiple different
versions of gameplay that you could have
here you got you know the on-the-ground
first-person-shooter version yeah then
you have fighting with the lifesavers
and you have fighting with throughout
your spaceships type of weapon exactly
and it looks like all of those features
are going to be exceptionally worthy to
use I don't feel like I'm going to walk
out of this game feeling like I only
like using the lifesavers on a fan of
the other version of it so like each one
of them is going to be is equally
exciting to use throughout like I was
saying for like the first one that came
out I felt like it was way more about
like the the gunplay yeah and with when
you played out the heroes like I said
they just seemed like they lunch well
with this one it looks like they're
going to actually give the Hero
characters more of like a different
moves they can use yeah so if you
actually do get to play with them you'll
get to use their specialty moves I hope
like four different characters they do a
lot of different moves even with the
shooting like and that it feels so good
that I hope like the classes are really
like in depth and like when you are Jeff
a guy
you sly up yet blast me Hannah but the
thing about the last one is that they
had a whole bunch of downloadable
content that feels like it should have
been in the game so I think that's why
like this one's going to be yeah how
much better I remember that's what the
and refactor was yeah everybody was just
like why are we going to pay for like
the fool this should have been the fool
yeah this just looks beautiful I really
feel like they got a winner right here
where there's gonna be no complaints but
there's always gonna be complaints but
they're really hitting it and I was when
I was doing the research for this game I
was I saw that they want to give you all
the DLCs that extend to come for free oh
cool I mean they're going to try to
figure out how to make some money off
you anyway but for that there was such a
big feedback that like the last one you
had by all the DLCs that they're just
like you know what we're going to give
it to you just because want you back
yeah it's more about the game than
having to worry about all the newest DLC
they're gonna come out of some too so
it's amazing that we don't have to worry
about that we just buy the game get all
the amazing stuff to come with it I'm
interested in it's like if certain
characters were stronger than other ones
let's say you could play a console a
little bit you're going to go up against
or small like there are small a little
better than him to where you feel like
okay I'm on solos Menace but I'm still
gonna get my ass shot should have the
old Han Solo bursting kylo Ren that
would be cool well I'm pretty sure is
you could pick all the different
characters in this game you can actually
do yeah I got all those characters
throughout like the whole span it's like
damn cool on a witch like who would
actually be able to go up against each
other like say like you could put two
villains against each other imagine
having a Boba Fett versus dark small
right or kylo Ren or any kind of a
different character like that it's
really interesting it's another game
that as the date comes out you got to
start streaming that because it's gonna
be a good one it look like they're
showing a lot more than Emperor so it's
really interesting I'm thinking that
like you're going to play more on the
dark dark side for this game so it'll be
really cool to see if you get to do that
or it's just you know you switch both
types you get to see what's going on
from the Jedi side you get to see what's
going on from Sid side some my favorite
parts of the
and all the Star Wars movies is episode
3 when he goes no no alright guys well
you can subscribe to the real reject
click that notification bell people look
out for more late trees or reactions
from the e3 shrimpies weak trees on
Instagram most importantly it's in the
gamer on Twitter live streams throughout
the week isn't doing it consistently my
friend Joe checking out and I'll guess
that some point we got playing just now
that I picked up the game for injustice
a couple of times now and justice too
we got to start bursting each other on
there I'm going on so I can show people
it's how much of your asses but not much
of your last kiss break you need Batman
and look at what I get quiet cuz I get
too competitive if I could be vibing
that I would be five right away right
but there he doesn't exist in that game
special [ __ ] ass excuses that's what I
tell my life